so excited to be on the floor right now
first of all it's so comfortable but it
is self-care awareness month and you
know we're all feeling the stress these
days i think it's been two years of
stress
work rising costs so we're going to talk
about some very easy ways to deal with
the stress joining us this morning alina
karate a certified kundalini it
kundalini instructor okay so i have
we've got to talk about kundalini
breathwork master sound healer first
what is kundalini for folks at home
kundalini it's a very ancient yogic
practice it's a very precise practice
that actually allows you to completely
reprogram your nervous system and your
endocrine system okay so this is perfect
for self-care absolutely
why do you think you know self-care has
taken a little bit of a
back road lately
well let me start off with that we live
in a frequency-based reality and our
thoughts and our emotions are going to
determine the way we experience the
reality
and self-care is an act of love
so when we are hearing on the news all
of these atrocious things going on all
around the world
we're having negative feelings that
we're embodying we're going to be
attracting similar experiences so they
are not analogous to love aha so the the
important thing is because we are
constantly dealing with some of the
negative out there is to find the
positive so
what is if you will like one technique
that people could do at home very easily
to embrace
some some some beauty and some happiness
i like to call it tiny habits so in the
morning you get up and you brush your
teeth and you could add a little tiny
habit on after this routine of yours
that you have brushing your teeth doing
some simple breath work okay how do we
do it
well one of my favorite ways it's called
alternate nostril breathing so all you
need is your thumb your finger your
forefinger and two nostrils okay easy
enough
you're gonna take your thumb you're
gonna plug your right nostril okay and
we're gonna inhale through the left okay
and then block the left exhale through
the right
and then continue
oh
so here you are voluntarily commanding
your pineal gland to take control of
your pituitary gland and
re-revamp your endocrine system your
glandular system interesting yes wow
okay so folks that's so easy to do at
home just a little breath
talk to me about the sound here because
we have all these beautiful bowls how
does this work so this is one of the
easiest ways to attune to a positive
vibration
and each one of these bowls resonates
with a different center energetic center
on our body okay chakras some of us have
heard of it some of us have not but i
would love to just play a couple yes
please do so wherever you are just get
settled take a deep breath
everybody has 30 seconds in the day to
just slow down
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
oh elena that's so relaxing
just allow these ethereal energies to
enter you
wonderful
folks i could sit here all day long i'm
sure you could we'll put her contact
information on our website so that you
can
do this have elena come and help you
heal with your vibration thank you so
much for being here this morning we
appreciate that and